Okay,
I guess since you started your videos
and since you started having troubles
with know with human rights tribunals or
threats by u of t and I just think it's
common sense that I said that I think
that promoting critical thinking,
helping people to be able to tolerate
subjects that they may not feel
comfortable about,
but then they should be able to hear and
process not based on emotions but based
on an actual analysis of the facts,
the evidence,
the reality versus some agenda being
shoved down their throat,
whether it's media through the
professors and anyone teaching in
academia knows that there are professors
who have no problem with basically
teaching their truths as fact.
And so I've been promoting this,
promoting it within my own organization
that are the Ontario Psychological
Association.
I got a lot of flack from other
psychologists who thought,
no,
we can't allow this type of speech to
happen.
That's a discussion that you're supposed
to have had.
The Travis didn't really,
um,
it was October I believe when you had
those other professors coming in and
talking about,
you know,
the issue somewhat.
Some psychologists wrote pieces in,
in national art,
a media publication saying this kind of
discussion should not happen.
Yeah,
okay.
So and this from psychologists,
the ones who are supposed to be best
trained to be able to tolerate the
discomfort that goes around.
It goes along with,
you know,
discussing uncomfortable topics.
So I was hoping for you to be able to
share with,
you know,
the audience,
your experience in the last few months
in trying to promote this.
I,
you know,
what you were basically trying to
promote,
which I think I'll let you describe in
your own words.
Okay.
So where do you think about those videos
for a minute?
Well,
I think there were two things that.
Oh,
I should give you some background on the
videos I guess.
I mean I just made them in my office at
home.
I wasn't,
I had no idea what the consequence would
be.
I was just trying to sort out my
thoughts about pardoning both.
Not so much bill [inaudible] as the
background policies that surround it,
especially on the Ontario Human Rights
Commission website because the bill
itself looks rather innocuous.
It's only about two paragraphs long.
The only part of it that isn't innocuous
is the insistence that
the insistence on transforming the hate,
the hate speech codes,
including including harassment and
discrimination based on gender.
What was it?
Gender identity and gender expression,
right in the hate speech codes.
I thought that's.
That's weird that there's something out
there.
Anyways,
I started digging more into the
background on the Ontario Human Rights
Commission website and the policies
surrounding bill [inaudible] to call
them appalling is barely scratched the
surface there.
They're unbelievably badly written and
contract internally contradictory and
over inclusive and dangerous and I mean
they do things,
for example,
like make employer's responsible for all
the speech acts of their employees
whether they have intended or unintended
consequences.
That's completely the only reason you
would write a law like that is to get as
many employers in trouble as you could
possibly manage because there's no other
reason for formulating the legislation
that way and I've also.
A colleague of mine came in recently
from at the university and he's starting
to teach a little bit about the
background for this sort of thing and
one of his classes and he showed me the
developmental progression of the
policies surrounding bill c 16 and
originally they were written in a much
more in a tighter format,
but then they were farmed out for what
they call public consultation,
which basically meant they ran them by a
variety of people who I would say are
very strongly on the activist end of the
political spectrum and they basically,
in order to not bother anyone who they
had consulted with,
they decided,
for example,
that gender identity should be nothing
but subjective choice,
which is.
I don't even know what to say about
that.
If you're a psychologist and you have
any sense at all,
that's a completely insane proposition.
It's first of all predicated on the idea
that your identity is your subjective
choice and that's never been the case
for any sort of identity.
Anywhere you you take your identity is
twofold.
The first thing that your identity is a
functional set of tools to help you
operate in the world,
meaning read Piaget,
you know,
we've just scratched the surface of
piaget even and you find out that,
you know,
children start to construct their
identities really when they're
breastfeeding because that's when you
first started your social interactions.
You start integrating your re.
Your basic biological reflex is from an
agenda perspective into something
resembling a social relationship because
breastfeeding actually happens to be
quite a complex act and then you expand
your,
your developing identity out into the
small microcosmic social world of the
family basically starting with your
mother.
But then you have siblings and your
father and your relatives,
you know,
conventionally speaking and your
identity is a negotiating game and
you're not the only one in charge of it
by any stretch of the imagination at
all.
I mean,
one of the things that Piaget pointed
out was that between the ages of two and
four,
and I think later research has really
hammered this home,
that even kids who are hyper aggressive
at two,
if there's a small proportion of them
that are like,
that learn to integrate their subjective
desires into a broader social game and
become socially acceptable to other
children and they do that through play,
you know,
what they're doing is playing their
identity into being.
And then once they're older than about
four and they've become properly
socialized.
So other children actually want to play
with them because that's the critical
issue.
It's the fundamental issue.
Then,
um,
then then the,
the peer community of children helps
bootstrap their identity up to something
that will eventually approximate and
adult identity.
But that's functional.
It has nothing to do with whim.
It's,
it's,
that's a,
it's a crazy idea.
And then so,
so partly your identity is the set of
tools with which you functioned in the
actual world.
And part of it is a negotiated agreement
with the other people around you.
And that's all being taken out of that.
That's,
that's all actually as far as I can
tell,
that's line of theorizing is technically
illegal now in Ontario,
and I'm not even talking about the
potential biological basis of identity
because of the idea that identity has no
biological basis,
that's just wrong it united factually
wrong.
So,
and we've written a social
constructionist,
we've written a radical social
constructionist view of identity into
the law,
but even worse than that,
we've gone beyond social constructionism
because piaget was a construction
constructionist into just pure.
When your identity can be at any moment,
what you assume that it's going to be,
that's not a tenable solution.
It's.
There's nothing about that proposition
that's reasonable.
So I was looking into this and I thought
this is just beyond comprehension that
we've written that idea into the
policies surrounding bill c 16.
So that.
So I made that video.
I was trying to sort that out and to
figure out even what it meant.
The terminology is messy in the extreme.
First of all,
with regards to gender identity,
gender identity is not a spectrum.
It's a modified by modal distribution.
And if you're making law,
you don't get to muck around with the
words,
you have to use the right words.
And so it's a modified by mode of
distribution because almost everyone who
has a biological identity of male or
female identifies as male or female.
It's 99 point seven percent and you
could argue that that's a little tighter
than it would be if society was more
accepting of gender variation,
let's say.
But even if it went down to 99 percent,
which would be an increase of like
what?
Well,
it would be almost an order of magnitude
increase.
You still have the overwhelming number
of people whose gender identity matches
their biological sex.
And then you can match.
You can stack on top of biological sex,
gender identity,
virtually perfect match.
Then gender expression.
Almost everyone who is biologically male
or female who identifies as biologically
male or female expresses themselves as
male or female.
And then the vast majority of them have
a sexual orientation that's in keeping
with their,
you know,
in traditional keeping with their
biological sex,
gender identity and gender expression.
So now we have a laws that says those
are independent guests.
What?
That's not the definition of
independence and you can't just play
much games with your legislative
terminology.
It gets,
it gets people in trouble so it's not a
spectrum and that's that.
It's a modified by mobile distribution.
If there are obviously exceptions and I
never argued once in the videos
that I put out,
despite what,
how people reacted to them that there
weren't exceptions.
Of course there are exceptions and if
you look at temperament,
for example,
you know the big differences between men
and women are agreeableness and
neuroticism.
Fundamentally,
women are about half a standard
deviation,
more agreeable,
that's compassionate blindness,
and they're about half a standard
deviation,
higher in negative emotion and that's
cross cultural by the way,
and it also accounts for the reasons why
women are about three to four times more
likely to suffer cross culturally from
depression and anxiety.
Whereas men are more likely to be
aggressively in prison and to and to
drink and low agreeableness is actually
the best predictor of incarceration
among manner.
Those are solid biological differences,
but if you try to segregate men and
women using only those two dimensions,
you want to get it right about 75
percent of the time.
So there's substantial overlap,
but that still doesn't mean they're,
that's not a spectrum.
And the idea that there are no
biological differences between men and
women,
it's such a preposterous claim that I
can't even believe that we would ever
have that discussion.
I mean,
there's,
we have men have wider jaws,
men are taller,
they have broader shoulders,
women have more endurance and endurance
sports.
Women have a subcutaneous layer of fat.
The shape is different.
The way the arms are placed is
different,
the voice is different.
Um,
and that's just gross morphology and not
even talking about genitalium.
And then you can look at
microstructures.
There's differences between men and
women at every level of the human
microstructure,
from the cellular all the way up to the
social.
So like what in the world are we talking
about?
What's going on here?
It's crazy.
So that was video number one.
Video number two was a bloody a human
resources department at the University
of Toronto has adopted an equity
position.
Okay,
so what equity means is that it doesn't
mean equality of opportunity.
It means equality of outcome,
and that is a.
So this is the idea.
The idea is that you take as a social
institution like a university,
and then you look at the organization of
that university at every single strategy
from the executive level,
all the way down to the student level.
Then what you do is you do an analysis
of each level by community demography,
right?
You get to define the demographic
characteristics that you're going to
discuss however,
which is actually a big problem.
Then you make the presupposition that
unless that organization at every level
matches the demographic representation
of the people at every level,
then it's corrupt,
oppressive,
and discriminatory and it needs to be
changed.
Okay,
so you think,
well,
what's wrong with that?
Every level should have 50 slash 50 men
and women,
let's say.
It's like you're really sure about that.
Are you?
You're so sure about that.
You don't think there's any natural
differences in interests between men and
women?
Well,
if you don't think so then why are most
psychology classes,
80 percent women and that and that and
that differentiation is accelerating
rapidly.
Like I've seen it over the course of my
career from maybe 60 percent men at the
beginning of my career to like 80
percent women now and men occupy more of
the positions in the stem,
in the stem,
a stem fields,
at least for now.
It's the same in bloody scandinavia.
It's 20 to one nurses,
20 to one women to men,
nurses in Scandinavia and 20 to one men
to women in engineering and that's in
Scandinavia and so what's happening in
Scandinavia as they've made this site or
egalitarian in terms of its legal and
social structures is that the gender
differences in personality between men
and women have got bigger,
not smaller.
So what that means is that social
constructionism is wrong.
That's what it means.
Wrong disproved.
It's exactly the opposite of what the
theory would have predicted because the
theory predicted and God only knew how
it was going to sort itself out.
It's like,
not like people knew this to begin with.
The idea was that as you equalize the
social,
the social,
uh,
structure that the differences between
men and women would disappear.
Guess what,
that didn't happen and it's not.
Studies have just a few hundred people
in a few locations,
those are population wide studies and
they'd be replicated multiple times.
So,
and the funny thing is,
is that,
so they're temperamental differences
between men and women.
It's and neuroticism and F and
agreeableness are not the only
temperamental differences.
So if you fragment extroversion,
it fragments into um,
assertiveness and gregariousness women
are more gregarious.
Men are more assertive.
If you fragment conscientiousness into
orderliness and industriousness ness,
women are more orderly at men are more
industrious if you fragment openness,
which is the creativity dimension,
into interest in ideas and interest in
aesthetics.
You find that women are more interested
in aesthetics and men are more
interested in ideas.
So,
so because you've been fractionated the
big five into 10,
you get gender differences across all of
them and they're not trivial either.
They make a difference.
So.
Okay.
So anyways,
back to the equity thing of all the
preposterous and idiotic ideas,
so first of all,
to make gender equity across every
dimension of a,
of a,
of an organization who have to assume
that men and women have identical
interests or and,
and temperaments and that if they don't,
the state should intervene to bloody
well ensure that they do,
which is something for all you women to
figure out because now there's many,
many what
positions in society that women
preferentially occupied.
So what are you going to do about that
and what are you going to do about the
Asians because they occupy preferential
positions as well.
You know,
they're overrepresented in all sorts of
professional institutions and the
probability is that that's going to
increase.
What are you gonna do about that?
What about the Jews but are going to do
about them because they have,
they're in the same position as they
Asians going to put quotas on all those
people.
What kind of stupidity is bad?
And then it's worse too because let's
say you equalize women and just for the
sake of argument across all these
different dimensions of society.
Well then what are you going to do and
you get to equalize for black women and
Latino women and Asian women.
Are you going to sub type black women
because it's not like they're all the
same.
Are you going to ensure that women from
lower classes are are represented just
as much as women from upper classes and
how many generations back are you going
to go to check that?
What about intelligence?
What about attractiveness?
How about height?
How about weight?
So the problem with the fractionation by
group identity is that it's endless.
There's no way of ensuring equality
across groups because there's an
infinite number of groups you can
fragment group identity all the way down
into the level of the individual,
which is exactly what you should do,
which is what we already did in the
west.
We figured,
well,
the ultimate diverse population,
there's a population of individuals.
So you let the individuals sorted out,
no,
we're going to replace that with group.
Well,
what that means for the bloody social
activists is that they'll be able to
play this game forever because you can
continually functioning group identity
ad nauseum and so the system will never
be equal and you can bloody well be sure
that as we implement social policy to
make sure that all outcomes are equal,
the amount of space that you personally
are going to have to maneuver in is
going to shrink and shrink and shrink
and shrink.
We've already seen that happen in many
societies.
You think we would learn from the 20th
century,
so that's the equity issue,
and then worse,
even this is the HR and equity people
there actually mucking about with
people's unconscious biases.
So this is what we want,
right?
We want your employers and the state to
reeducate you so that your perceptions,
because that's what we're talking about
with regards to unconscious bias,
so that your perceptions fall into in
accordance with their demands and not
even your voluntary perceptions.
By the way,
your,
your involuntary unconscious perceptions
have to be retrained.
Okay?
So maybe that's not so good,
especially when you look at that bloody
implicit association test mastering
biology from Harvard and Anthony
Greenwald from the University of
Washington.
So biology is an avowed Marxist and
Greenwald and both bloody well know and
have written that there are implicit
association task has neither the
reliability northern validity to be used
as an individual diagnostic tests.
They know it.
Sorry,
just something like I've collected about
that in my class that not everyone is
aware of that.
Do you want to just give up?
I can bring up a powerpoint slide or do
you want to.
Why don't you do that?
Do you want,
do you want to do that?
Yeah.
So I'll let you take over when you do
that.
So despite the fact that.
Sorry,
this
will take me a minute.
So
yeah.
Well despite this,
okay.
So the implicit association task,
the principle is this word association
game.
It's actually predicated,
I would say on psychoanalytic ideas,
most particularly on union ideas because
young develop the association test many,
many,
many years ago.
But it purports to investigate whether
you are unconsciously bias towards one
group against another group.
Could be gender,
could be ethnicity,
could be race,
could be attractiveness,
whatever.
But the problem is,
is that when you give the same person
that damn I met twice,
they don't get the same results.
So there's a rule for diagnostic tasks.
And the rule is the reliability test,
retest reliability has to exceed
something like point eight or point
nine,
point eight at least.
So the big five does that,
Iq tests do that,
but there's a dam,
uh,
there's damn few tasks that passed that
reliability criteria.
And the,
it is the only reliable,
I don't remember precisely,
but I think it's about point five,
which isn't even,
it's not even near close enough to be
used as a diagnostic test.
Plus it's not valid.
So what does that mean?
Let's say I assess your unconscious bias
and give you a diagnosis.
Well,
there's no evidence that it predicts
your behavior.
So.
So what,
what good is it?
What good is it?
Well,
it's good if you want people to send you
to retraining exercises so that you can
have your perceptions adjusted in the
direction that your organization in the
state thinks is proper and that's
happening everywhere.
I got letters this week already for
people at CBC.
It's becoming mandatory there.
St Mike's Hospital,
same thing,
and they've decided that all of their
micro institutions within the hospital
will be equitable.
There'll be 50 percent women and 50
percent men at every single level of the
organization or the organization is
corrupt and oppressive.
It's like it's and that it's spreading
so fast.
You can't believe that.
I wrote Mazur and Banaji and Anthony
Greenwald yesterday.
I hadn't set it off to some of my
colleagues say,
are you going to come out and make a
public statement about the fact that
your damn test is being used by
pathological people for nefarious
purposes?
It's like,
well,
we'll see what they have to say about
that.
I was a bit more polite in my letters,
but there's no excuse for it.
There's absolutely no excuse for it and
as far as I'm concerned,
is part of the broader corruption of
social psychology.
You guys may know or may not.
The social psychology has been rife with
with a controversy and scandal over the
last three or four years and a big part
of the reason for that is it's damn
corrupt.
Discipline and that use of the iat for
political reasons is a perfect example
of that.
There is no excuse for it and the people
at St Mike's,
you know,
they say,
well,
this is scientifically validated.
It's like,
no,
it's not and worse.
Let's say you do have unconscious bias
just for the sake of argument and you
could measure it reliably,
which you can't,
and then it was valid,
which it isn't.
Let's say all of those things were in
case there's no evidence whatsoever that
those damn unconscious bias training
programs,
retraining programs have the effect that
they're supposed to have and there's
some evidence that they actually have
the reverse effect and maybe that's
because people don't like being marched
off to reeducation by their employers
after they've been diagnosed as racist.
Even if there's no evidence that they in
fact are so,
it's an absolute misuse of psychology
and it's in.
It's.
It's politically motivated.
It's an assault on freedom.
Anyways,
I made those two videos and I took,
tried to take the HR and equity people
at unt to task because they made that
training mandatory for their hr people.
I thought,
you don't have the right as an employer
to invade the unconscious structures of
your employee's minds and alter their
political perspective.
Even though you can't do it.
You don't have the right to do that and
to think about it as something you
should do.
As a matter of course,
as part of your ethical duty is
you really want that.
You really want that.
That's what you want your employers to
be able to do.
Figure out independently of your
behavior whether or not you're like
you're a racist or classist or or a
misogynist or whatever that happens to
be and you already think that the
bureaucrats at the university,
for example,
or bureaucrats anywhere for that matter
are actually capable and qualified of
doing such a thing properly without
doing far more damage than,
than any possible.
Good.
Well,
so anyways,
I made those two videos trying to sort
this out into investigated in them for
whatever reason,
you know the proverbial well,
you know what happened by within two
months there was 180 newspaper articles
written about it and I don't know how
many millions of people have watched
these things online now,
but it's plenty and so what that also
means is I put my finger on something
because who cares what it did when it
professor from the University of Toronto
does with his spare time at midnight.
No one should care.
I should have had my 15 minutes of
notoriety if that.
But that isn't what happened.
It was,
it was major news in Canada for three
months and I'm still talking to people
all over the world about it.
I get a hundred letters a day,
at least I can't keep up with them about
pete from people who are being cornered
in all sorts of ways by their idiot
employers and these safe space
propositions at universities and the
restrictions on their speech.
They can.
They tell me constantly,
well,
I really agree with you,
but I'm afraid to say anything about it.
So like,
oh good.
That's a wonderful position for us to be
in where people are afraid.
They're afraid to speak their minds,
what the hell and it's not getting
better and if we don't do something
about,
it's going to get a lot worse.
You saw what happened at Berkeley.
That's just a taste of what's to come.
You know,
one day there's going to be an
antifascist demonstration with a little
bit of violence and the bad guys on the
other side.
You're going to come out and we're not
gonna like that very much.
So maybe we should get our acts together
and stop that from happening before it
actually happens,
unless that's what you want and I
wouldn't recommend it.
We have a pretty sophisticated society
and it wouldn't take much to put a
spanner into the spokes and with
everybody on their forehead.
So wake up for Christ's sake.
It's this is not good.
And the fact that the fact that,
you know,
the bloody federal government has
decided that they won't let people pick
the judiciary or unless they take
unconscious bias retraining.
Right.
What hail.
It's crazy.
So
anyways,
that's what happened
in addition to ideologically driven.
Just to that,
do you think of.
I'm always quite cynical.
Do you think it's also a make work
project for a bunch of people that they
figure,
you know,
we can create these tests that aren't
valid,
aren't reliable,
but we've got an industry,
you know,
that that's going to keep going forever
now.
But you'd never expect social
psychologists to be careerists with you?
Yes.
Yes,
definitely.
Well,
I mean it got out of hand too.
It's not,
you know,
people don't necessarily plan these
things.
I'm sure that the Ontario Human Rights
Commission,
when they were talking about preferred
pronoun use,
had no idea whatsoever that within four
years of introducing the policies that
there would be 71 different gender
identity categories.
No one saw that coming.
How could you possibly see that coming?
And I don't think Banerji and Greenwald
had any idea that there tests would be
transformed into an implement public
policy so rapidly.
Right?
So,
okay.
And just for those who are interested,
the,
uh,
the implicit associations,
their implicit attitudes test,
um,
my students,
I always give a link to that.
And if anyone's interested,
I can give you a link where you can go
to the test and actually do it yourself
and find out.
Because the assumption is that if you
are implicitly racist,
so explicitly racist.
Say I hate blacks,
I say implicitly racist.
Oh No.
Some of my best friends.
But when you do this test,
the idea is that if you're shown a black
person's face,
okay.
Versus a white person's face,
you're more likely to associate that
black person with us a violence.
So you're basically being primed
unconsciously is when you see a black
face,
if you subsequently see a weapon and
you're asked to decide whether this is a
weapon or a tool there more quickly
going to say weapon because you're
already thinking dangerous violence
weapons because you know,
you have this negative association of
blacks with weapons and you'll do that
faster than when you see a white face,
the white face to be more neutral.
So whether you see after the white face,
a gun or a weapon in theory should be
about equal,
equal time to determine whether you know
it is one or the other,
things like that.
This is the kind of test that they do
and they've associated or they've done
this test as Dr Peterson,
same with countless other types of
constructs.
And again,
the reliability,
the validity is not just suspect,
it's just,
it's not existent.
And um,
as I said,
if you'd like to try it out,
if,
um,
if you're a student check out on the
bright space page,
if you're not,
email me,
facebook me and it'll give you the link
and you could have done it too,
like I think 50 different,
at least you know,
Democrat Democrats,
Republican,
the vanilla strawberry,
that there's all these different things
that you can do and see where your
implicit or unconscious biases are.
And as Dr Peterson saying,
it's getting out of hand and this whole
idea of the gender pronouns,
because during the debate that you had
or whatever that was at the u of t,
one of the people that I think she was a
lawyer,
very condescendingly ran across with.
That's right.
She's like,
oh,
this kind of thing would never happen.
You don't know what you're talking
about.
What,
first of all,
the Human Ontario human rights tribunal
page,
they specifically say that Jen,
you know,
that,
uh,
you have to identify people by their
preferred identity or expression,
which includes pronoun usage.
It's there on their page.
It's not explicitly stated in Bill
[inaudible],
but the Ontario human rights tribunal
who will in fact enact any type of
action against somebody who's,
you know,
who's violated these policies.
Okay.
It's on there.
Very page.
And I know you spoke about your own
experience.
I hope that because not everyone saw the
debate.
Can you just talk about that part where
it's speaking to other professionals who
don't seem to be ideologically driven
like Kaufman?
Uh,
what they said about the,
the risks.
Oh,
sexually,
this is so important.
It was interesting.
I mean,
she's,
she's definitely not looking at this the
same way that I knew.
One of the things she said we're in a
rather condescending manner was that I
wouldn't be sent to jail even though I
wanted to be.
I'm paraphrasing,
but that's roughly what she said,
but that you know,
that the human rights tribunal could
take away my property in my wages and
all of that,
but that seemed to be okay for her as
long as it didn't extend to jail.
But that's also nonsense because if
you're,
if you're found guilty by the human
rights started getting land,
you don't pay,
then that's contempt of court and that
goes to a different court and then they
put you in jail and that's already
happened.
So it's,
it's,
it's crooked lawyer,
hand waving fundamentally,
and it's an attempt to play down the
significance of the law.
You go and read about you online and
read about the powers of the human
rights tribunal and then see how safe
you feel.
So here's one of the things they can do.
This is section one,
point six.
It's in a document about powers of the
powers of the tribunals.
They call them social justice tribunals.
In Ontario,
they actually called the social justice
tribunal.
It's mind boggling.
They can suspend precedent,
lead normal legal precedent and
jurisprudential tradition in the pursuit
of their age.
That's one of the.
It's actually documented as one of their
powers.
Think about that.
Like we live in a society that's
essentially bound by the restrictions of
English common law.
English common law is one of the most
remarkable
developments of civilization ever,
period.
Because what?
See,
in the English system,
basically the presupposition is that you
have all the rights,
there are,
they're not enumerate,
you just have all of them except when
one of those rights imposes a
restriction on someone else and then
they get irritated you and take you to
court and then the judge sorts out who's
who has which micro,
right and then that's laid out is
precedent and so English common law is
this tremendous body of evolved doctrine
about how the infinite number
of human rights that each individual has
interacts with everyone else's rights.
And like back when Trudeau Trudeau
brought the human rights code,
the bill of rights,
the Canadian bill of rights,
there were lots of people who were upset
by it because it's a different form of
legal reasoning.
The bill of rights says,
here's the rights you have that the
government is granting you.
That's not how it works under the
English code.
The English code is you have all the
rights there are,
but they rub up against other people's.
Right?
So we have to sort that out.
We do that with court and precedent and
that's what the Human Rights Commission
and tried people in Ontario can dispense
with if they want,
and the reason there,
I know the reason that they put that
line in there,
it's because the social justice
hypothesis is that the legal structures
of Western civilization are oppressive.
Patriarchal,
uh,
are oppressive and patriarchal and so
it's perfectly reasonable to toss them
over.
If you're in pursuit of something like
social justice,
it's like,
that's fine.
People,
sure,
go ahead and do that.
But if you think that you can transform
what we have already now into some kind
of utopia,
then you're dangerous because that isn't
how the world works and Utopians it'd be
more dangerous than any other people for
the last hundred years.
That's for sure.
Like there's all sorts of things wrong
with Western society always,
and there always will be,
but compared to 85 to 90 percent of the
rest of the planet,
this is bloody heaven.
And that's why people want to move here.
So you can say,
well,
it's corrupt compared to my imaginary
utopia.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
It certainly is,
but if your imaginary utopia was
realized in in hardcore politics over a
30 year period,
everyone would be out in the streets
starving to death.
We already know that because it happened
multiple times throughout the 20th
century in societies that were.
Well,
they weren't as sophisticated as our
society is now,
but they were plenty sophisticated for
their time and you'll hear the neo
Marxist types.
This is the most annoying argument ever
anyone ever makes.
They say,
well,
what happened in the Soviet Union that
wasn't real communism?
It's like first,
Oh yes,
it was.
That's why it also happened in China,
which was a very different society,
but what they really mean when they say
that as well.
You know that stellan character,
he wasn't such a good guy.
He didn't really know how to implement
the Marxist doctrines,
but me,
I'm pretty pure of heart and if you
would have made me dictator for 20
years,
then the utopia would have arrived as
promised.
It's like,
first of all,
if you think that there's something
wrong with you,
you're dangerous.
And second,
let's just say for a minute that some
saint did get ahold of the tools of
power and try to implement from each
according to his ability to each
according to his knee and actually did
that in a pure and safe manner.
Here's what would happen.
The next people in the revolutionary
string,
like Stalin would come along and stab
them in their band in the middle of the
night and that would be the end of that.
So No.
So there's absolutely no excuse
whatsoever for that sort of thinking.
And if you read Solzhenitsyn's school
like archipelago,
which you should do like everyone should
because it's like the definitive
document of this sort of thing emerged
that emerged from the 20th century.
Solzhenitsyn laid out with extraordinary
clarity first in his writings on Lenin
and then in his writings on the Soviet
Union more broadly,
exactly how the current dishes and
pathological Marxist doctrines were
transformed logically and systematically
into the sorts of laws that killed
millions of people.
Millions of people.
There were people starving so badly in
the Soviet Union by the 19 twenties that
they had posters telling them not to eat
their children.
So we've been down that road already.
So what the hell are we doing?
We're going down that road again under
the guise of equity,
right?
And,
and,
and equality.
Well,
that was the doctrines that promoted
those laws to begin with.
Not Good.
Okay.
So
when Dr said when you did,
when you talk this way,
some people are going to say either
you're pulling things out of proportion
or you know,
you've made a huge leap from where we
are now to where we should be.
And so I think there's a lot of room for
misunderstanding for people,
especially if they have certain
ideologies that they would like to
protect.
So one of the reasons I want to invite
people over was to be able to ask
questions.
You've heard Song Dr Peterson's,
uh,
tenants that he's trying to convey.
Um,
and he said,
you know,
and I don't have any videos.
Each person has watched,
but you have an opportunity right now.
That's okay.
If someone,
if someone has a specific question
either from somebody talking to Peterson
has said today or things you've heard,
the videos will be negative.
I really want to ask them face to face,
straight up,
what do you mean by this or what is your
solution to that?
Please?
I'm opening up the floor.
Just talk really loud.
Please let Mike can pick it up and that
everyone's going to hear.
Does anybody have a specific question
that you'd like to ask?
Okay.
Oh,
sorry.
I'll let
Barbara K.
okay.
It's a little bit of a Sidebar,
but I've watched.
I've watched your videos.
They're resilient than some of your
longer ones and explained and I.
I'm intrigued by your.
I know one of your heroes was a great
man.
I'm a little disturbed.
I would love to know why was the anti
Semitic,
you know,
the book that he wrote in which he was
accused of antisemitism has not been yet
translated into English.
There's only one place.
Well,
one of the things that he did,
but he certainly.
There's certainly no sign of
Antisemitism in the Gulag archipelago.
Not as far as I could tell and I don't
think in the other books I've read,
I haven't seen that either.
He did write a book near the end of his
wife on the role that Jewish
intellectuals played in the
establishment of the Soviet Union,
but you can't get it in English,
so I don't know what to say about that.
I know that it's being criticized from
both sides.
I would say one side saying,
well,
this was a story that needed to be told
and the other side saying,
well,
this sphere is it down anti anti
Semitism.
So.
But you would ask that question.
That's the question.
Okay,
so
I'm going to venture out on a limb
because I've been thinking about this
for a while.
Am I going to venture out on.
No,
I've.
I haven't gotten my thoughts formulated
well enough.
The leftest doctrines tend to be very
attractive,
the intellectuals and so any group
that's overrepresented in intellectuals
is likely going to be overrepresented on
the left,
the standard of the spectrum,
and there are temperamental reasons for
that.
We know that if you lean left,
it's because you're hiring openness and
lower in orderliness and that seems to
be associated with,
with ICU at least in part,
but I don't want to go into it any more
than that because because I haven't
thought it through sufficiently,
but I also haven't been able to get a
coffee and social mentors last book
because you can't get an English hasn't
been translated for one reason or
another.
So,
but I don't think you'll see anything
like that in the Gulag archipelago.
There's another question before I'm
going to ask.
Have you asked the question but after we
get back to this,
because you mentioned a number of times,
both the correlates between Iq and the
left and that um,
the,
uh,
people who believe in the support
thought police are not actually,
they're not left.
Is there a whole other category of.
Yeah,
that's such an important distinction to
turn to in a few minutes.
But first this question please.
So the current proposition in
regards to how you
going.
I think we're doing a good job of that
right now.
I mean,
how fast do you think things,
how fast could you even hope for things
to change?
Look at what's happened to the situation
and limits inspected with women since
1970 has changed so fast that people
can't even keep up.
It's not obvious by the way,
are there that it's been particularly
good for women now you could make a case
that it was good for society.
Maybe it's a tough one,
a because the birth rate has plummeted
and so maybe you don't care about that.
Maybe you think there's too many people
on the planet already,
whatever,
but if it isn't that easy to figure out
when something is working property,
one of the things we do know we seem to
know is there to the degree that rights
are extended to women economic
prosperity follows.
So you can see worldwide that the
societies that have extended the rights
to women most extensively are also the
societies that seem to be flourishing
economically and there does seem to be a
causal relationship,
but women have paid a big price for
that.
So what's happened in part is first of
all for for say a women who were middle
class or lower their their lights if
essentially fallen apart because
marriage is now restricted to the ranch,
which is also something to think about.
For those of you who think marriage is
oppressive,
patriarchal institution.
It's like,
okay,
then why are only the rich people
getting married?
They're oppressing themselves.
I don't think so.
And so the women who are in the lower
socioeconomic stratus are suffering,
Madelyn and so are their children and
they have terrible jobs most of the
time,
like jobs in retail where you know,
they're called in every day for the next
day.
They don't have a schedule that it set
out ahead of them.
They get paid very badly.
They've got kids to take care of and so
they have no free time.
It makes them really easy targets for
useless predatory males and it's really
hard on the kids and that's like 40
percent of the female population.
Something like that.
You guys,
while I don't know about all of you,
but you're in university,
you're part of the privileged cognitive
elite.
You know,
so these sorts of things don't really
touch you the same way they touch other
people and so women are much happier if
you look at national polls than they
were say in the late 19 fifties and
early 19 sixties.
And I think that's partly because
freedom and happiness,
those are not the same thing.
They're not even close.
And now I see young women all the time
struggling to figure out what to do with
their lives because they have no idea
how to have a job slash career and a
family.
So.
And there's no answer to that.
It's a really difficult problem,
you know,
and there's all sorts of ideas.
Like I did a lot of consulting for law
firms for a long time,
about a decade and I had a lot of
clients who were extremely high
functioning female lawyers,
younger ones trying to figure out how to
balance their career with their desire
to have a life.
And you know,
you hear all the time about women being
denied access to positions of power and
that that's uh,
that's the consequences of prejudice and
oppression.
It's like,
yeah,
everything is caused by the same thing
first,
right?
You have got one causal principle.
Wonderful.
Now you're a philosopher.
You can figure out everything with it.
It's like the law firms cannot keep
their women in their thirties.
They cannot keep them.
The big law firms,
they all leave.
Why?
Because the women hit 30.
They're brilliant.
Conscientious,
intelligent.
They were deadly in highschool,
deadly,
and university.
They nailed law school.
They whipped through their article.
They made partner by the time they were
30 and it's like they're in a rocket to
the top position.
What do they find when they get their 80
hour work weeks?
Right?
Because that's one of the things you
want to think about.
You know,
you think that the people who run things
are sitting at home smoking big cigars
and like
telling their minions what to do.
It's like that is not.
That's like the 19 twenties millionaire.
That's on the cover of the monopoly
game.
Going sociological analysis.
I know lots of people
or like that and they work all the time.
All the time.
Second,
they wake up until the second they go to
sleep and they don't just casually work,
you know,
because I know some of you go to the
library for six hours and you say,
well I studied in the library for six
hours.
Like no you did you study for half an
hour coffee
and you look through facebook and I went
home and you said,
well I studied for six hours and you're
happy about it,
but you don't bloody well you did part
because you can't,
you know,
I can only read for about three and a
half hours until I'm done and I'm pretty
good at it.
So these people who are running things,
there's corrupt people obviously,
but the vast majority of them first are
self made.
Its second.
They're so bloody efficient and smart.
You cannot believe it.
And they work 80 hours a week at.
Most of them happened to be mad.
And why is that?
Because there are a small number of
insane men who will do nothing but work
80 hours a week and no matter where you
put them,
if you put them in the middle of a
forest with an ax and all they would do
is run around chopping down trees.
So the issue isn't why aren't there more
women in positions of power?
It's why are there any men insane enough
ever to occupy those positions?
You know,
because we also know and the data on
this,
it's very clear what's the relationship
between money.
It will be once you have enough money to
keep the bill collectors from your door.
So once you have enough money to stave
off misery,
which is sort of lower middle class,
something like that in our society,
maybe a little little lower than that.
Extra money does not help you.
It does not improve your life.
So why bother with it?
Well,
that's what the women in the law firms
think.
It's like most of them,
by the time they're in their thirties,
are married.
Almost all of them are married to men
who make as much money or more than they
do because that's what women go for
cross culturally four to five years
older,
equal or higher in socioeconomic status,
so their.
Their husband's already made $350,000 a
year.
It's like they think,
well,
I don't need much more money.
The man used money to keep track of the
competition by the way,
because all the male lawyers that I
talked to,
her usually real hard ass guys really
low in agreeableness,
really high in conscientiousness,
like conservative types,
low in openness as well and they want to
win and the reason they care about your
damn bonus at the end of the year isn't
even so much because of the money.
It's because they got a much bigger
bonus than the other son of a bitch
sitting beside them and they're happy
about that.
So there's a real,
like a real brass knuckles competition
that drives these sorts of things,
but we get things backwards so often in,
in,
in psychology and in sociology.
It's not why there aren't more women in
positions of power.
It's whiting.
Any men want those positions,
you just have no idea the amount of
responsibility that comes along with
that.
You just imagine for a minute trying to
run a billion dollar corporation.
You can't even bloody well balanced your
checkbook and there's dust bunnies
underneath your bed.
How in the world would you ever run a
billion dollar corporation?
Those things are complicated and you
have enemies and they're trying to take
you out all the time.
You look at apple and Samsung,
man,
they're just torturing each other in the
courts nonstop.
You know,
you'll,
if you're,
if you're running a big corporation,
you'll be.
You'll be handling two or 300 lawsuits a
time and that's just,
that's just nothing compared to the
complexity of what you actually have to
do.
Stay on top of the technology,
constantly interact with your large
customers.
Travel all the time because you have to
maintain the relationships.
You have to regulate the politics inside
the business.
You have,
believe me,
it's no picnic and you think,
well,
they get a lot of money.
It's like,
what makes you think that's such a good
thing?
You know,
like if you're a half crazy and you have
a lot of money,
you're going to be crazy a lot faster,
I can tell you that frees you from all
sorts of constraints.
You know,
we know the data on lottery winners,
they're no happier a year later and some
of them are done,
especially if they had like a bit of a
cocaine problem to begin with because
you know,
being broke stops you from dying.
If you're a cocaine addict,
if you get enough money and the way you
go and you think to yourself,
you know,
you've got all sorts of bad habits,
weirdnesses.
If somebody dumped an infinite amount of
money on you,
what makes you think you would unravel
completely?
It's highly probable.
So anyway,
so back to these women,
you know what they do in their thirties,
they look around and they played hit
partner so they hit the pinnacle of
their profession.
They think,
what the hell am I doing this for?
Why would anyone in their right mind
want to be woken up at three in the
morning,
Sunday by they're irate Japanese client
who wants them to work for the next five
hours nonstop to fix this damn problem,
which is going to cost them $100,000,000
right now,
or we'll find someone else to pay $750
an hour or two to fix it right now.
When you think,
well,
that's,
you know,
a masculine form of value that.
Because that's one of the criticisms.
If the law firms just adopted a more
feminine structure of value,
it's like what kind of bullshit is and
the reason,
the reason that you get up,
it's three in the morning on Sunday to
talk to your Japanese client was
freaking out about their contract is
because if you don't jump the hell up
and do it right now,
there's some starving associate who's
unbelievably ambitious in New York will
pick up the pieces and two tenths of a
second and they're smart and aggressive
and they'll take you out.
So it has nothing to do with masculine
structures of values.
All the foolish ideas.
And you know,
it's not just law where this happens,
you know,
we know for example,
that female doctors were far fewer hours
too.
So the more female doctors you have,
the more doctors you have to have.
And I'm not complaining about women's
priorities.
I'm not saying that women are wrong.
Not at all.
It's like the older I get,
the more I understand that marriage and
family are a primary importance.
And the more I see women in particular,
no,
they hit 35 or 40 and they're not
married,
they don't have kids and they are not
happy because what the hell are you
going to do from the time you're 40 till
the time you're 80,
you've got no family,
you got no relationships.
What are you going to do?
Go Run your company.
Yeah.
Well if you're one in a thousand that'll
satisfy.
So you well better make sure you're that
one in a thousand and you're probably
not because those people are rare.
So.
So,
so then,
uh,
Dr Peterson one of the natural response
to what you said,
would it be okay?
Well,
the priorities are,
it's a rigged game because only when
there are the ones who are able to
procreate.
So what do we answer to that?
Of course it's a rigged game.
Obviously it's a rate game.
Women have complicated lives and the
pill has made them more complicated.
Well that's not.
I wouldn't say that exactly because you
know,
100 years in 18,
95,
the average person in the western world
lived on $1 a day in today's money.
Okay?
So those people worked so hard at slaved
away to such a degree that you can't
even imagine it and all their kids die.
Right?
So they,
that the death rate among kids below
five years beyond comprehension.
And so like women have terrible time as
well.
So did men.
They got to be coal miners and soldiers
because now that wasn't exactly
entertaining,
you know?
So life was very,
very,
very hard before we got rich and we're
rich.
Even those of you who are in this class,
we think you're poor.
It's like,
no,
you're not,
you're in the top one 10th of one
percent by historical standards.
And probably there by world standards as
well.
Of course you can just compare yourself
to the few people who Richard than you
and feel sorry for yourself.
But that's pretty pathetic in my
estimation.
So it's ended certainly historically
uninformed.
So yeah,
women have it rough obviously.
Now there's,
there's other things to consider.
You do live eight years longer,
so that's not trivial.
Testosterone kills men.
That's basically why men die earlier.
You know,
men are much more likely to be killed in
dangerous jobs.
They do almost all the dangerous jobs.
They do almost all the outside work and
there's lots of reasons that men get
paid more than women that have nothing
to do with the prejudice.
It's because they take awful,
horrible jobs like working in the oil
rigs in northern Alberta,
but it's bloody 40 below and come out of
that after five years with two or three
fingers missing and,
and all warped up because you really
want to wrestle pipe when it's 40 below
and it's filthy with a bunch of ordinary
man who are hung over beyond belief.
It's like that's not very entertaining.
So yeah,
I mean each gender,
each sex has its own unfairness to deal
with,
but to think of that as a consequence of
the social structure,
it's like,
come on,
really,
what about nature itself?
And this is something,
this is something that seems to be
completely invisible on the left side of
the political spectrum.
It's like,
of course you're bloody oppressed and
your life is full of suffering
obviously,
but to think about that as a direct
consequence of unjust social structures
is just moronic.
It's like that's part of the reason a
small part,
but look where you're sitting people,
it's pretty warm in here and you're so
privileged.
You can come here at Saturday morning
and listen to an intellectual lecture.
It's like you should be happy about that
because by historical standards you
should be out lifting rocks in your
skeletal form about five foot three with
no teeth.
Cougars,
cougars alliance.
Yeah,
exactly.
So you know,
there's no gratitude.
That's the thing.
There's no gratitude for what our
society is capable of doing.
So a three.
Yeah,
Dr Peterson.
Tell them what do you think about that?
Because I was thinking what happens when
the forces of the gender identity,
gender expression clash with the Marx,
the capitalist market forces,
for example,
sports is a multibillion dollar industry
and if some women start saying we
express ourselves as bad because we're
mad and the law is on their side.
Do you think that this billion dollar
industry is going to come out with some
women wanting to be football teams on
the Toronto Maple leafs?
I don't think so.
Sad.
Whenever you do of the market forces
will will clash with this and then some
of these issues.
Well,
market forces will be a constraining
factor.
Partly because the market tends to
punish things that don't work in the
market very,
very rapidly.
You know,
and that's another thing with regards to
thinking about say equality or equity in
the workplace.
If you believe that there is a
equivalent distribution of talent across
all the categories,
that you have some reason to wait for
the market to sort itself out because
you know,
even if you're a,
an anticapitalist,
you at least have to understand that the
people that you despise are motivated by
greed.
And so they're going to try to find
people who will make them the most money
and they basically do that.
It's a pretty stupid employer who won't
take someone tell them to when they come
along and you might say,
well,
they're prejudiced and they're not doing
such a great job of,
of like sorting out the applicants.
It's like,
that's fine.
There'll be stomped real good by people
who are much better at it because like
talent is unbelievably rare.
I don't know if you guys have talked
about the freedom distribution at all,
but.
Well,
productivity is not normally
distributed.
You don't even learned psychology.
That's everything is normally
distributed.
It's like,
no,
it's not
random.
Things are normally distributed,
but productivity isn't random.
And so what you see that productivity is
actually governed by something called
price's law,
which is a variation of another
principle called the preto principle,
which was discovered back in the late 18
hundreds by deal Fredel Pareto who was
an economist.
What price showed he price actually
studying scientific productivity.
And so what he shows,
it's quite cool.
At the time when he did this,
this was in 1960,
the typical phd student had one
publication on graduation,
okay,
half as many had two,
half as many as that had three,
half as many as that had a massive step
down in productivity and you see this in
beside in scientific productivity
periods,
so what happens that in any given
scientific domain,
there's a clump of people sort of on the
left side of the distribution,
the less productive side and there have
an in that clump.
Men and women are equally productive,
but then there's a tiny percentage of
people who publish all the papers and
they're all men and they're those insane
man that I was telling you about before
that do not work for 80,
almost a week.
And the thing is,
if you want to rise to the top of a
profession,
do you think about it?
What do you need to rise to the top of a
competitive profession?
You better be smart cars,
smart makes you fast and you're not
going to get to the next place faster
than anyone else.
Unless you're faster than them.
You bloody well better be conscientious,
industrious in particular,
so it should make you feel horrible
every second of your life you spent
doing something that involves leisure
and there's going to be some people in
here that know that Mr hyperconscious
branches,
I can't stand sitting around doing
nothing.
I got to find some art to it.
You know,
when you'll do whatever you have to
that's work because you feel guilty and
horrible if you're sitting around.
So you need to be hyper conscientious
and so maybe you need to be in the top
one percent for intelligence and maybe
the top five percent for
industriousness.
So that's one percent of five percent.
So you're looking at it.
I think that's one of that.
What is that one percent?
Five percent?
Yeah.
One in 100.
One in 20.
One in $2,000.
I think that's right.
Anyways,
you're a rare bird if you're going to be
in that position.
And so,
um,
because because of the credo
distribution and because of the
concentration of productivity in a very
small number of people,
there's tremendous economic incentive to
identify those people no matter where
they're from.
No matter who they are and employers who
have any sense know that and they're
hungry like these law firms,
you know,
you don't have no idea that knots,
they tie themselves in trying to keep
their qualified women because those
women are worth a bloody fortune.
You know,
they pay them a lot,
but they bring in way more business
than,
than they bring in far more economic
resources.
Then they take the law.
Firms want to keep them.
Now that doesn't mean the man,
all the men in the law firms don't have
no problems with highly qualified women
because they don't know what to do with
them.
You know,
like if you're a guy and you're
assertive and competitive,
then you're going to be asserting
yourself and competitive with other
guys.
But it's a lot harder to do that with a
woman because you think,
well,
what am I?
How am I going to be?
Am I going to be like hyper aggressive
around her because that just doesn't
work out.
And so the guys,
we don't know what to do about that.
And I would say there's some residual
trouble in law firms and other high end
industries because of that.
They just don't know how to sort it out.
But mostly the employers are thinking,
I don't care if you're green,
if you're a smart and you can bring in
business and you're reliable and you can
solve problems like we don't have
anybody like you,
we need you,
please stay.
Doesn't happen.
So yes,
the market forces will.
But the market forces I think are
already going push things hard and then
in the direction of maximizing the
utility of television because you just
have no idea how much more productive a
productive person is.
Then a nonproductive person.
It's crazy.
I just to that a publication which is to
get your blood boiling.
Yes.
Somebody said to me,
glaciers,
gender and science,
a feminist glaciology framework for
global environmental change research.
You want to talk about productivity.
And then there's academia
that degree all of academia.
But unfortunately,
I mean this is a profession in which,
uh,
people have killed them truly in the
trees for bullshit basically.
So I just thought that would be ironic.
Twist,
yeah,
well you know the postmodernists,
they don't believe in.
I don't know how much you know about
postmodern philosophy.
You're at Ryerson,
so probably quite advanced,
but not at the uft is any better because
it's not,
but the postmodern is don't believe it's
science.
There's lots of things they don't
believe and they don't believe in logic
and I'm not making this stuff up.
Like you can go read it for yourself.
In particular,
they think that logic is part of the
oppressive patriarchy and that there's
no point in dialogue because all the
reasons different power groups
identified by their groups and they
can't really talk.
It's just a power struggle and that's
why the radical leftist stop people from
speaking on campus.
That's why I couldn't find anybody to
debate me rough and speaking at the
University of Toronto and I went to
Queens University two weeks ago to the
law school there because I was invited
by a group called Runnymede Association
and they asked six professors if they
would debate me.
It's like,
no,
why not?
I'm not even a lawyer and lawyers can
debate like they're.
They're good at that.
That's what they're trained to do.
No,
they wouldn't debate me,
so they had to get somebody to play
devil's advocate and he did a good job.
You know,
he did a very credible job,
I thought,
but you think,
well,
why would they come debate me?
That's easy.
They don't believe in dialogue,
period.
It's part of the philosophy because you
have to believe in logic.
First of all,
to believe in dialogue.
You have to believe that people can
communicate as like as individuals
fundamentally and not that you're just
locked in your identity as a group
member against all the other identity
groups that are struggling for power in
the Kinda hobsy and landscape that's all
part of postmodernism.
So and this,
well,
this is just an extension of that.
It's like science is just a patriarchal,
oppressive,
patriarchal structure and so we need to
reconstitute it from.
It's from the bottom up.
It's like they type on their computers
while they say this.
Not noticing that by the fact that
they're using the damn computer,
which wouldn't work.
You know?
People had to figure out quantum
mechanics before they could make
community computers.
They use the computer science,
doesn't.
Science isn't real.
They do the same thing when they're in
jet planes.
Science isn't real 600 miles an hour
typing on my computer so I could six.
That's called a performative
contradiction from a philosophical
perspective and that's the same as a as
a logical paradox.
You don't get to say one thing and do
another and say that you've got it while
you do,
if you're a postmodernist because you
can do whatever you want if you're a
postmodernist and the reason the damn
postmodernists are Marxists as far as I
can tell,
because inevitably they are,
is because the problem with
postmodernism is it doesn't even leave
postmodernists anything to do because
postmodernists don't believe in
overarching directional narratives.
And the problem with that proposition is
if you don't have an overarching
directive narrative for your life,
you don't know what to do and it's
really important that you know what to
do because you're alive,
that you need to do things well.
We'll just turn back to the original
Marxism and we'll say,
well,
we'll just get.
We'll just group ourselves up in
oppressed groups and we'll have wars
between the oppressed groups that'll
give us a sufficient overarching
narrative.
Doesn't matter that it contradicts the
postmodernist thesis because they don't
care about contradictions so.
Well.
So hence this feminist glaciology.
Okay.
So I've got a few questions.
Let me watch your hands pop up.
So there's one back that first
you've
been determined as
women
and
gender choice or not choice?
It's a good.
It's a good question.
No,
I don't think so.
Even though I think your question is
well formulated,
that intelligent,
I don't think it's that the economy is
that straightforward because there's a
tremendous amount of deterministic
thinking on the social justice warrior
in the distribution to because they
regard you as the deterministic product
of your environment.
So it's more like the localization of
determinism.
So you might say that for the dialogue
for the more biologically oriented
people,
there's more biological determinism but
then so,
so I think that the,
the,
the conflict between free will and
determinism basically runs across the
entire political spectrum.
But then I would also say it's probably
an ill formed argument because there
isn't an absolute paradoxical
contradiction between free will and
determinism.
Quite the contrary.
You actually need elements of
determinism,
I think for a system to operate freely.
So for example,
think about playing chess.
You can do a lot of things when you're
playing chess or think about composing
music.
You can do a lot of things when you're
composing music,
but there's an underlying rule structure
that sets up the,
the,
uh,
the environment within which all of
those choices manifest themselves.
The same with online video games,
which,
which are reading good example,
I think because they are micro worlds
and they're determined in some sense
because they have an underlying rule
structure that's the rules of the game,
but they're free in many other ways.
And so I don't think there's anybody
pretty much on any side of the political
spectrum who would regard people as
entirely possessed a freewill.
You know,
we have constraints and limits and the,
we're also pretty good at adjusting
those on the fly.
So for example,
you'll be much less irritated if at
three year old runs into you carelessly,
well tryciclics than you will if a,
you know,
an adult man runs into with his scooter
because you'll,
you'll take,
you'll take the constraints of the
individual into account very,
very rapidly.
So I think so.
Well,
so that's,
it's not as simple as free will versus
determinism mount onto the political.
You mentioned that somebody thought that
socialism was
a,
there's a,
there's something wrong with that person
and see what you're saying.
I wonder.
I asked her to say those are the video
about compassion,
about how people get their compassion,
altruism and that you appeal to an
individual.
It seems that like attacking that,
that's not your peer,
but it seems that even get people on
their heels sort of,
you know,
I see like some hatred for Americans
or Muslims and,
and I think that just makes people they
naturally feel identified with like
their land,
their category.
It'll just make them defend that stance
even more reaching for the individual,
like understanding compassionate.
Okay.
So I take that apart a little bit
because is a bunch of issues with the
question,
how many people are in your psychology
course or taking psychology or most of
you taking psychology courses,
how many people are taking psychology
courses?
Okay,
so a goodly number.
Well,
one of the things you want to do with
the conception,
like compassionate as you actually want
to start thinking about it like a
psychologist or like a scientist,
because compassion is actually definable
and it.
I think the easiest way to approach it
is to think about it in big five terms
because it.
It maps onto agreeableness and
especially you can break agreeableness
down into compassion and politeness and
the liberal types,
especially the social justice types are
way higher in compassion.
It's actually their,
their fundamental characteristic and you
might think,
well,
compassion is,
is a virtue.
It's like,
yes,
it is average you,
but any unit,
dimensional virtue immediately becomes a
vice because real is the intermingling
of a number of virtues and their and
their integration into a functional
identity that can be expressed socially
and compassion.
Passion is great if you happen to be the
entity towards which it is directive,
but compassion tends to divide the world
into a crying children and predatory
snakes.
Right?
And so if you're a crying child,
hey,
great man,
but if you happen to be identified as
one of the predatory snakes,
you better look the hell out.
And so,
you know,
compassionate is what the mother,
grizzly bear feels for her cubs when she
eats you because you got in the way,
right?
Exactly.
So,
nope,
we don't want to be thinking for a
second that compassion isn't a,
uh,
a virtue that could lead to violence
because it certainly can.
And the other problem with compassion,
this is why we have conscientiousness,
right?
There's five canonical personality
dimensions.
Agreeableness is pretty good if you're
dealing and getting akin system,
you want to distribute resources
equally,
for example,
among your children,
because you want all of them to have not
only the same chance you even walk them
roughly to have the same outcome,
a good one,
but the problem is,
is you can't extend that moral network
to larger groups.
Not as far as I can tell you need
conscientiousness,
which is a much colder virtue and it's
also a virtue that's much more concerned
with larger structures over the longer
period of time.
So and you can take about
conscientiousness is a form of
compassion to.
It's a strange form.
It's like straighten the hell up and
work hard and your life will go well.
It's like I don't care how your
feelings,
how you feel about that right now.
And and like someone who's cold low in
agreeableness say and high in
conscientiousness,
that's what they'll tell you every time.
Don't,
don't come whining to me.
I don't care about your feelings.
Do Your Goddamn job.
Are you going to be out on the street?
Think,
oh that person's being really hard on
me.
It's like not necessarily.
They might have your long term best
interest in mind and you're fortunate if
you come across someone who's like not
too radically disagreeable but
moderately disagreeable and high in
conscientiousness because the whip you
into shape.
And that's really helpful.
I mean you,
you'll admire people like that.
You won't be able to help it,
you know?
And you think,
Oh wow,
this person's actually giving me good
information even though you know,
you feel like a slug after you after
they've taken you apart.
So okay,
so that's the compassion issue.
It's like you can't just transform that
into a political stance and I think part
of what we're seeing is actually the
rise of a form of female
totalitarianism.
So we have no idea what totalitarianism
would be like if women read because
that's never happened before in the
history of the planet.
And so we've introduced women into the
political sphere radically over the last
50 years.
We have no idea what the consequence of
that is going to be,
but we do know from our research,
which is preliminary,
that agreeableness really predicts
political correctness,
but female gender predicts over and
above the personality trait.
And that's something we found very
rarely in our research.
Usually the sex differences are wiped
out by the personality differences,
but not in this particular case.
And then,
you know,
women are getting married later and
they're having children much later and
they're having fewer of them.
And so you also have to wonder what
their feminine orientation is doing with
itself in the interim,
roughly speaking and lot of it's being
expressed as political opinion,
like in fair enough.
You know,
that's,
that's fine,
but it's not fine when it starts to shut
down discussion.
But also if you think about politics,
politics from a temperamental
perspective,
if it gets to be extraordinarily useful.
So if you have conservative,
you're high in conscientiousness,
particularly orderliness and you're low
in openness.
Okay,
so what good are you?
Well,
you're not great.
If you had to have a wonderful
philosophical conversation about ideas
and then go ahead and art movie.
It's like no conservatives,
you're wrong.
Wrong date for that particular bit of
business.
But if you want someone to run a company
that's already been established or to
make sure that algorithmize processes
are being undertaken properly,
you want conservatives,
they're very good at managing and
they're very good at administrative
conscientiousness is the best predictor
of those two domains part from Icu.
Okay.
So fine.
What do you need the damn liberals for?
Well,
you don't want them running anything but
you want them thinking up new things
because the entrepreneurs and artists or
are high in openness and low in
conscientiousness,
especially orderliness and they have to
be because if you're starting something
new,
you don't want to have everything in the
neat little boxes.
You have to break rules,
you have to take things apart and so
that liberals need the conservatives to
run enterprises and the conservatives
need the liberals to start them and then
you.
It makes sense from a temperamental
perspective,
if you think about it too,
because there's five basic personality
dimensions.
They're all normally distributed and
what that implies is that there's a
niche for every personality type in
proportion to the frequency of the of
the occurrence within that normal
distribution.
There's some places for really
extroverted people.
There's more places for people who are
moderately extroverted and moderately
introvert,
but there are places for everyone in
that dimensional structure and there's
utility for all of those people and so
that's why you have to keep the dialogue
going.
It's like if you're hyper liberal,
you have to talk to the damn
conservatives because sometimes they're
right,
sometimes you're right,
but sometimes they're right,
and so if you don't talk then the system
tilts off to the,
to the,
to the extreme that's represented by
that temperament.
And so what you'd have is a bunch of
liberals talking about new things while
the buildings were falling down around
them.
So.
So we need each other and that's part of
what's happened in the West is we
figured that out a long time ago.
We figured out,
oh well you haven't got to talk to those
stupid people who don't think the way
you do because sometimes despite the
fact that they're annoying and nowhere
near as smart as you,
they're actually correct.
And so here's another way of thinking
about.
Imagine the environment.
Does this like a snake?
It's always moving,
right?
You don't know where the damn thing's
going and you want to be in the middle.
It's like to cliffs that keeps shifting.
You want to be in the middle of far from
the cliffs.
It keeps moving around and you're trying
to walk forward.
Well,
sometimes it's over here,
so the conservatives,
they have to pull it back and sometimes
it's over here,
so the liberals,
they have to pull it back and.
But because it keeps changing,
you don't know who's right and so you
have to keep talking and that's what a
democratic society actually allows for
exchange the opinions move the damn
polity so that we can stay in the middle
of the snake,
roughly speaking.
And so you got to have some respect for
people who aren't like you.
They're actually not like you.
So I figured out recently I think that I
couldn't figure out why openness and
conscientiousness are the dimensions
that are determining political belief
because they're not even correlated.
So why the hell do they clump for
political belief?
And I think I figured it out.
I think it's because of a borders.
I think the fundamental political issue
is how open versus closed borders should
be.
And I don't just mean borders between
states.
I mean borders between states,
I mean borders between the institutions,
the borders between genders,
borders between sexes,
borders between ideas.
The Conservatives say,
keep everything where it belongs because
it's working and the liberals say,
yeah,
it's working for now,
but unless we make some adjustments,
it's not going to keep working and
they're both right,
so we better have the dialogue because
otherwise we wander off the cliff on the
left or the right and we know where that
goes.
That goes.
There's flames down at the bottom of
those events and people die horribly
down there and we've seen that on the
right and the left with.
We've had plenty of evidence for that.
So
smart sort of friends
and I have like.
It feels like their compassion got
twisted somehow and I have compassion
for that.
I don't like.
I want to speak to to that.
These are people that I love and stuff
like this and I think that they are kind
of ideologically twisted such
well.
One of the things I've also spent a fair
bit of time thinking about is the role
of the resentment plays in political
ideology and I have recommended in my
lectures,
but I'll recommend it here too.
There's a great book by George Orwell
called Road to Wigan pier,
which I wouldn't Wyg in which I would
highly recommend what orwell.
He was a leftist.
He went and fought with the on the
communist side in the Spanish civil war
against the fascists roughly.
I mean,
Orwell was a tough guy and very,
very smart,
super smart.
And he went up to visit the coal miners
in the 19 thirties and in,
in,
in northern,
in northern Uk.
I mean,
those people bad.
They had to crawl to work for two and a
half miles in a tunnel.
It was like three and a half feet high
just to get to their shift.
And then,
you know,
that meant breaking rock for seven and a
half hours.
Then they had to crawl back and they
didn't get paid for the commute,
you know,
so they had rough time and they have no
teeth by the time they were 30 and you
know,
they were done in old by the time they
were 40.
It was rough.
And so,
you know,
orwell went up there and said,
Jesus,
industrial nightmares,
just killing these poor oppressed
people.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure,
and he lays it out.
You can read that without thinking a
thank God I'm not a coal miner and be.
Yeah,
it's pretty rough at the bottom of the
industrial revolution,
like seriously rough,
but in the second half of the book he
did an analysis of socialist philosophy.
One of the things he pointed out was
that his observation was that the sort
of middle class,
ideologically bound socialists types
didn't care for the poor at all.
They just hated the rich.
It's like,
yes,
that's right.
Not everyone.
I worked for the MVP when I was young
and I met a number of the leaders of the
MDP,
including grand oddly.
I knew him quite well.
He was Rachel Notley's father because we
come from the same town and I had a lot
of admiration for the leaders of the
back then no,
because they were really trying to give
a voice to the working class.
It's like,
you better give a voice to the working
class or you had never electing trump
for example,
but you know,
the Socialists have abandoned the down
working class.
It's like,
no,
we'll go play identity politics and
staff like that worked out really well
for Hillary Clinton.
I noticed so because it was identity
politics.
That's certainly shifted the election
towards trump.
She lost the working class people.
Well,
someone has to give them a voice so
there are genuine.
Are People on the left were genuinely
working to better.
The lot of people who because of
situation haven't had the opportunity.
They might've,
but so many people are resentful.
It's like,
no.
If there's some people out there that
have more than me,
that's a terrible thing for North
American to think.
It's like we're so goddamn privileged
that you know,
we should spend at least one extra day
in hell after we die for every time we
complained about how poor we are.
Right.
Oh,
there's some people who are richer than
me.
Yeah.
That's pretty rough,
man.
That's,
that's a rough break for you.
You're still.
It's the funny thing you hear about the
one percent all the time in North
America.
It's like,
oh,
the one percent.
First of all,
that's a moving target.
People in the one percent shift like
crazy.
You have,
I think about a 10 percent chance of
being in the one percent at one point in
your life and about a 40 percent chance
of being in the top 10 percent for at
least one year of your life.
So there is a one percent,
but it's moving,
but you're the bloody one percent.
Oh,
you have to do is compare yourself with
the rest of the world.
So like what are you complaining about?
These tiny proportion of people who have
more than you,
like what's up with you?
How can you be so clueless that you
would do that?
How can you be so ungrateful and
arrogant and blind?
It's terrible.
I mean,
people have rough lives and the rest of
the world,
I mean,
we're making people,
Richard Very fast,
you know,
300,000 people a day now get connected
to the electrical grid and about 250,000
people lifted out of abject poverty.
We wiping out abject poverty faster than
ever before in human history by a huge
margin.
So that's all for the good.
It's really impressive.
But,
but a huge chunk of that twisted
compassion is just resentment.
So since there's a few people who are
better off than me,
maybe if I compare the two myself across
one dimension,
Jesus dismal.
But that's what that was getting lost in
the discussion today.
It's all,
it's so deflecting outward.
It's all trying to,
you know,
it's say it's like,
it's this resentment is this wanting and
stuff like that.
It's this lack of gratitude for just how
lucky we really are.
And it's just this complete lack of
insight and reflection.
I think that's a big problem.
Well,
it's partly lack of historical knowledge
and it's like people,
it's easy to take what we have for
granted.
Here we are,
the lights are off.
It's like some stupid poor son of a
bitches out there climbing some power
line in the freezing rain,
you know,
with this damaged arm to make sure that
we can all sit here and complain about
how oppressed we are.
You know,
it's pretty pathetic,
but it's no wonder we take it for
granted.
That's the funny thing because your
minds are organized so that if something
always works,
you ignore it because well why would you
pay attention to it?
Right.
It always works.
You don't have to pay attention to it,
so as soon as something is predictable,
you zero it out and so then you think,
well,
in courses like this,
this is just how it is.
It's like,
no,
this is not how it is.
It's a bloody miracle that this stuff
works ever.
It's crazily improbable and it always
breaks,
right?
Everything is always breaking all the
time and somebody out there dealing away
trying to fix it.
Yes,
so we're ungrateful partly because we
take things that work for granted.
If our systems worked only 99 percent of
the time,
our society would probably be better
because when the lights went off,
everyone would go and the and the heat
that,
oh yeah,
you can't see in the dark pool.
Then there's no furnace and it comes
back on and you think,
Oh yes,
that's much better,
but it always works,
so.
Okay.
That's great.
Yes.
Speaking of envy and resentment,
would you care to comment on the
apparently well established numerous,
this idea that men have a collective
common collective interests and women
have a separate common collective
interests,
class interest,
and that these interests are becoming to
conflict.
There's a competition sometimes on a
collective level.
Well,
I think there is competition between men
and women,
but it's nested inside a broader arena
of cooperation.
You know,
this is another thing that you learned
from reading Psj if you're,
if you're careful this,
but because piaget was smart enough to
understand that there is no dichotomous
opposition between cooperation and
competition.
So you know,
one of the sort of tenants of the kind
of this Mumbo jumbo that I hate is that
you should.
Kids shouldn't play competitive games,
right?
It shouldn't be cooperative games.
It's like,
okay,
let's take that apart.
Let's take hockey.
Is it competitive or cooperative or
competitive?
Well,
wait a second.
No one brings a basketball to the hockey
game,
right?
No one brings a chessboard.
Everyone that comes to the hockey game
comes there to play hockey.
That constitutes cooperation.
We'll mutually define the aim or does
piaget and cooperation.
We'll mutually define the aim,
will assign each other rules.
We'll all agree to stick to the roles.
Well,
that's cooperation and if you break the
rules,
what happens?
You get stuck in the penalty box.
You're not playing hockey off you go.
And people,
people go off,
they go sit in the penalty box,
they don't go kill the referee with
go and sit in the penalty box,
you know,
six foot seven slash 300 pounds.
So okay.
And then you think,
well what about within the team
that cooperation or competition?
Well,
each team member is trying to be the
best player,
but try not passing to your colleagues
and see what happens.
You know,
even if you're a really good,
they'll just,
you're just a diva and no one's going to
be happy with,
you know,
they'll put horrible things in your beer
after the game.
So it's cooperation there as well.
And then there's a Meta level of
cooperation which is that everybody's
trying to improve their skills
simultaneously and so that,
that serves a higher order good.
And everyone's trying to learn how to be
a good player so that they can play many
games.
It's like,
well,
we shouldn't play competitive games.
So like you must've been educated at
noisey.
Sad.
It's very sad and it's so,
so ignorant for people who know
something about child development to say
something like that.
It's just what is with you,
where were you educated or where were
you educated is the right response.
So.
And then so with men and women,
well there is group competition for
example,
you're competing roughly speaking with
all your classmates,
right?
And some of the women are going to
outshine you.
And so that's,
that's tough for men.
It's particularly tough for men because
it isn't obvious how you compete full
bore with women.
It's not obvious and we don't know how
to solve that problem.
And then of course status in
relationship to the male hierarchy is
more important for men than it is for
women because women pick their mates
based on their position in the social
hierarchy.
And so that puts me in also in an
awkward way.
It puts women in an awkward position
too,
like a lot of your women,
let's say there's a fair number of you
here who have an Iq of more than 130
puts you in like maybe the talk.
You're one in 20,
95th percentile and then you know you've
got pretty good career proposition,
so like your pool of eligible mates is
minuscule that the data shows that
clearly $50,
if I remember correctly,
50 point increase in icu for a woman
decreases your probability of finding a
partner by 40 percent.
It's something like that.
It has zero effect for men by the way,
because men made across and down
dominance hierarchies,
one across the top.
So if you're a smart woman and you're
and you're attractive and you're young
and you're hardworking and you have a
good career,
it's like you need a man who's smart,
hardworking,
young who has a good career,
but he has to be a little better at
those things than you.
It's like,
good luck,
good luck.
It's going to be rough because there
just aren't that many people like that.
And so there's another problem that
faces women too,
which is you're not going to be smart
card working with a good career till
you're 30,
then you have to compete with 25 year
old women.
And so that's also an insoluble problem
because the thing about 25 year old
women is they put less stress on men.
Why?
Because they can have babies for an
extra five years.
So every guy pittance.
Yeah.
Y'All have kids sometime because he can
think that he can have kids.
He's 80.
What the hell does he care women?
No,
no.
Thirty 5:40.
You better get it together by there.
And so when you're 30 and you've got
your act together,
you've got those 25 year old women to
compete with very.
And men don't care about your damn
stamps.
So it's rough.
It's rough.
So there is lots of competition between
men and women,
but it's nested inside a much broader
domain of cooperation marriages.
This fundamental solution to that.
And I think the evidence for that is
also clear.
It's like it's better for women.
It's you have a better sex life,
you're healthier,
your kids are better off,
you're not nearly as likely to plummet
into a lower socioeconomic category,
which almost always happens to women who
get divorced because it's,
it's hard to one income,
you got kids,
good luck,
like you're poor and if you're not,
it's because you're working so often.
The only time you have to have a date is
with some psychopathic man.
His schedule around yours.
Yeah.
Well,
I've seen plenty of this man.
I'm not talking through my hat.
I know exactly what the hell happens
when you,
when you were a little older and a
little poor and a little more desperate.
It's not exactly fun,
so I wouldn't,
I wouldn't recommend that you end up
there.
So.
Okay.
On that.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Um,
it's two part question.
You mentioned you were talking earlier
about English common law.
About 20 years ago,
I read an article from a constitutional
expert who,
Lauren against he the negative
repercussions can come from
the way we wrote the charter,
really codifying,
um,
select the victim groups,
and um,
and,
and that we turned our back on 800 years
of English common law and,
um,
uh,
and effectively stepped away from the
rule of law.
And the second,
the second part to that question,
the great granddaughter of
a lack of stories which your,
that was your question and how those two
relate in my mind is my escape from a
communist country.
And,
um,
and I've had,
you know,
dinner time conversations for decades
now with Michael other brother though
about what that looked like and what
that felt like.
And,
and I think we're,
um,
uh,
well the Baldwin's great granddaughter's
question was important,
which we don't have the stories that
would inform us.
And you touched on that because some of
the stories from your experience,
horrible,
horrible.
And I know there's all kinds of
Canadians,
um,
and they actually are fearful for where
we are in society right now,
but they're frightened to speak out.
Um,
and I think bringing that back around to
the charter of rights and freedoms we've
codified,
um,
preferred,
but we've overlooked in that most,
most,
um,
trauma and abuse happens within groups
and also the case earlier we started
overlooked and it someone because just
because someone said it doesn't mean
that they're also not a perpetrator.
Um,
and that doesn't get,
um,
a lot of press.
So
yeah,
whenever anyone claims victim status
without simultaneously claiming
perpetrator status,
you should run away from that person.
It's like I'm a saint and everyone's
been hurting me.
It's not.
No,
probably not.
Sorry,
you're a saint.
Really?
I don't think so.
I doubt it.
I've imagined you have your fair share
of,
of abstract blonde to one of your hands,
just like everybody else.
And so people need to take
responsibility for that mean speed.
Okay.
So just one more
and I'm wondering if what you're talking
just reading now is basically what I
didn't know.
She didn't you decades ago.
Morning,
Oh yeah,
that was a catastrophe to lay that bit
of logical rationality on top of the
English law.
Common law system was a catastrophe.
It was unnecessary and it is resulting
in much of what we're seeing today.
The problem with the codify bill of
rights,
the rights conflict right now,
English common law dealt with it by just
saying,
forget we're not a new marine and you're
damn right.
So you have all of them.
Okay,
what problems are,
is that going to solve it?
We don't care.
We'll solve them one by one as they
emerge.
Brilliant.
It's an evolutionary approach to law.
Essentially.
English common law is phenomenal and we
made a huge mistake codifying our rights
I think,
and that that is part of what's put us
here and then building in the victim
hood of,
of groups,
that's a hell of a thing to tell someone
to your part of the victim group.
It's like,
it's so clueless historically too,
you know,
um,
that surfs in the Ussr who are pretty
much all Caucasian.
They weren't emancipated until the late
18 hundreds.
Like you don't have to go very far back
in anybody's racial history to find the
equivalent of slavery.
I mean,
okay,
surfs weren't slaves.
It's.
Yeah,
yeah,
they were.
They were.
They were sold with the property,
you know,
and so that's 150 years ago.
Slavery was.
Slavery was not some exception
perpetrated on the world by the United
States.
Every damn society,
virtually that ever existed up until we
invented machines,
ran on slave labor.
So saying,
well,
you know,
some groups have been affected more by
slavery in the recent past than others.
I think that's fair to say it,
but the problem is as well,
what exactly do you do about that,
Dan?
And who defines it to?
It's a big mess and besides none of it
is to be trusted anyways because all it
is is postmodern deal marks sleight of
hand.
You know,
Marxism got demolished in the seventies.
Demolished,
ruined was never to rise again.
The postmodernists sneaky friendships
and French intellectuals played a little
slight of hand.
Okay.
It's not the working class against the
wealthy.
It's the victims against the oppressors.
Great.
All we did was move the goalposts
slightly.
Now we get to play the same game.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a lot easier than thinking.
So yeah,
competence.
That's what they thought.
Oh,
that's a good question.
I teach about the gulag.
Archipelago is my personality class of
hold the dopey places to teach it.
It's like I,
at the beginning of the class,
I say,
well,
how many of you know that 30 million,
uh,
Soviet citizens were destroyed through
internal repression between 19,
19 in 1959.
It's like four people put up their hands
and they say,
well,
how do you know I watched your lectures
on youtube?
You know,
that's not taught in school.
Why?
I know why.
It's because the bloody intellectual
leftists have never apologized for their
complicity in the catastrophes of the
20th century for Germans,
apologized.
Sorry about the Nazis with the left wing
intellectuals.
They say,
oh,
well that was real.
That wasn't real Marxism.
So like,
oh,
okay.
How many carbs is have to pile up around
you before you're willing to question
your beloved it?
Theological presuppositions and face
your resentment and your narcissism and
your desire for destruction.
You don't like people anyways.
The planet has too many of them,
so like a nice warm.
I cleared that up.
Well then all the plants can grow again.
You know the club of Rome and they
talked about the population explosion
that was going to wipe out the planet by
the year 2000.
They say outright that human beings were
a cancer on the planet.
Lots of people think that.
It's like,
oh boy,
next put the atom bomb a phone in your
hands.
Human beings are a cancer on the planet.
What a hell of a thing to say?
You're saying that to a four year old,
I saw bloody professor at Queen's
University tell a whole room full of 18
year olds that if they had an ethical
fiber in their body,
they wouldn't have any kids or they'd
only have one because all they're doing
is going out there raping the planet.
It's like,
what?
You know?
What the hell?
What?
I don't understand that.
It's like human beings are hard on the
planet,
but it's pretty damn hard on us in
return,
you know?
It's like we're just sort of trying not
to die to miserably and we make a bit of
a mess.
Well,
doing it.
It's like,
yeah,
Chris,
we've only known for 50 years that we
were disrupting the oceans.
How fast do you think we can learn?
You know,
100 years ago,
Thomas Huxley,
who was a great biologist,
said,
the oceans are so plentiful.
It was not a chance we could ever put a
dam in them.
So I was only 100 years ago.
Fifty years ago we thought,
Oh man,
there's more of us and we're better at
this than we thought.
It's like,
okay,
how fast do you expect people to learn?
You know,
one generation,
one year,
we're trying to do our best.
Most.
Most people are trying to do their best
and some people are trying to do their
worst,
but most people are trying to do their
best and so we should have a little
compassion,
little sympathy for human beings instead
of considering ourselves like raping
patriarchal,
oppressive destroyers.
Of the world,
Jesus,
you don't like that label.
So cruel.
It's so mean.
It's,
it's.
It has no sympathy there.
It's like most of the people I know are
struggling hard to get fine.
Usually.
The other thing about people that's so
interesting and you really learn this if
you're a clinical psychologist,
is that every single one of you in this
room has at least one serious problem
that you're laboring under,
and that's why the whole handicap thing
is a big problem as well.
It's like,
okay,
you're not mentally ill this moment,
but you will be.
You'll be depressed or anxious or you'll
hit some trauma in your life that'll
take you out,
and even if you happen to be in the
small minority of people who are
physically healthy their whole life and
emotionally healthy,
you're going to have a family member,
a child,
a parent,
a parent with Alzheimer's,
a child who's got some illness.
You know you're going to be carrying
some vicious burden for most of your
life and most of the time you're going
to stumble off the work anyhow and do
your damn job and contribute to society.
It's like I can never,
I can't even believe that our system
works because you just have to talk to
someone for five minutes and they tell
you,
well,
here's the three horrible things that
happened to me in the last year,
and they're horrible things.
Their mother died of like,
you know,
some degenerative neurological disease.
Those are particularly entertaining.
And their father was alcoholic and he
used to beat them up and their sisters,
schizophrenia can,
it's like
right away they go and do their minor
hero wisdom for the day and the light
stay on.
It's like,
you know,
human beings were admirable creatures
despite the fact that we're,
you know,
finite and useless and vicious and all
of those things.
So
it did
incorporate
physician suicide.
Should I tell him what to do?
Well,
you should pay very careful attention to
their definitions of diversity.
And then you have to pay careful
attention to the criteria by which you
choose people.
You know,
it's very,
that's an extraordinarily difficult
question because it's a personnel
selection,
uh,
decision.
But one of the things I would say is,
well,
if you're looking for managers and
administrators,
screenings for conscientiousness,
you get about a point two,
five point three correlation.
You think,
well that's nothing that's wrong.
It switches your probability of hiring
a,
an above average employee from 50 slash
50 to 67 point five slash 32 point five.
If it's a point three,
three zero,
let's see,
sorry,
60 5:35 point three zero correlation.
And because there's massive variability
in the productivity of individuals
tilting,
your selection up to that degree will
have massive,
massive economic payoffs.
I've done the calculation.
There are crazy and there's no.
There's no bias in a conscientiousness.
Tests
test for hiring for that.
When the court says the board,
the board
during the diversity officer,
one of the things you might do is track
the shifting ratio of men versus women
in the corporation.
But that's the sort of thing that
requires a micro analysis.
Know like there's going to be an
increasingly.
There are many disciplines where women
are overrepresented at every single
level that's happening in university so
fast.
Don't be a damn man left in the Faculty
of Arts and science at 10 years.
It's like,
so for all you women who are looking for
mates,
you better be thinking about that
because when men of bailing out of
university so fast,
you cannot believe it.
I'm like,
I've watched the curves for 15 years,
so linear up for women linear down for
me,
and so you can think,
well that's really good for women.
It's like
that's so clueless is there can't be
anything that's bad for men.
That's good for women and vice versa.
I know another thing too.
That's okay.
So back to the board,
you have to say,
well,
the what's the industry?
How does that map onto the valid natural
interests of men and women?
Is there any evidence that we're hiring
stupidly and the mere fact that you
don't have as many women or as many men
in one place versus another doesn't
indicate therefore that your prejudice,
you have to buy the equity argument to
buy that.
And if you buy the equity argument while
you're done with anyway,
so,
so because you're going to fall down
that spiral move,
never get out of it,
you'll never hit equity.
Not a chance.
Now a lot of these corporations are
doing it out of guilt and fear.
You don't.
You said that people are afraid to speak
up for Jesus.
You just have no idea how afraid people
are to speak up.
And it's actually no wonder.
I mean,
I've made those videos.
It was like I got hit by a tidal wave.
No,
it freaked me right out and still does.
I can't believe what happened.
Like it's been.
I would say overall it's been good,
but it's not necessarily the kind of
good you would wish on someone.
I kind of would like to have my old life
back,
but whatever,
you know,
I knew what was coming.
So it was only a matter of time.
But people are so afraid to speak up.
You just cannot believe it.
Tenured professors,
those are the most protected people in
the universe and they're afraid to speak
up.
And that tells you a lot about what
people are like,
but I should tell you,
you shouldn't be afraid to speak up,
but I'll tell you something else.
You should be more afraid not to speak
up.
That's the thing.
It's like you're screwed both ways.
Pick your poison.
You can either suffer the consequences
of having a voice or you can suffer the
consequences of not having a voice.
And I would highly recommend that you
don't pick the suffering that goes along
with not having a voice that's dreadful.
And so you might say,
well,
if I don't speak up,
I'm safe.
It's like,
yeah,
you are for for the next 15 minutes,
but you sacrificed a bit of your soul.
You might need that thing to get through
life without getting all bitter and
twisted and resentful.
So if you've got something to say,
maybe even to your board,
you say it and you don't know what's
going to happen,
it might be bad.
It might be good.
Like silence has exactly the same
consequences.
So and Dr Peterson's hiring.
So when they get rid of it or they're
hiring to replace me there,
not by the way the university is backed
off completely and I'm sure that was a
big part of because of the older public
support,
you know,
not that I mean I'm not trying to paint
them as evil villains because they're
not.
But also the students were very
welcoming to me when I came back to
class,
which was a big deal because I was very
nervous when I came back to class,
like very nervous.
I didn't know what the hell was going to
happen or even if I was going to come
back.
So.
But
there's one more question or two
questions.
And then Colorado.
Okay.
Difficult for you to say
you would not recommend that today's you
attended university in the traditional
sense.
Um,
so I to know what advice you would have
for people as far into the clinical
psychologist or want to pursue any
further education.
Don't take any nonsense.
Read the damn classics.
You don't know in clinical psychology
programs here,
you're reading that bloody waiting,
derald sue or whatever his name.
Is it a microaggression guy.
You know,
it's like,
here's how you do cross cultural
counseling,
so I know that that's a bunch of things
you don't do.
Like,
I mean,
that's what the books are.
Here's things that you shouldn't do if
you're doing cross cultural constantly
and that's helpful,
but what are you going to do?
Reading Freud,
read young,
read Adler,
greed,
Rogers,
read mass up.
These people knew what the hell they
were talking about.
The behaviors get,
get yourself educated with regards to
neuroscience.
There's lots of great things out there
to read and if your professors are too
stupid to teach you what they should
teach you with you,
you got to educate yourself and
university anyways,
you know,
so,
so that's what I would recommend.
The institution is corrupt always.
And so you know,
you're lucky you're lucky if you're in
graduate,
graduate school,
like one in five classes is really worth
taking.
You know,
you can't get too cynical about that.
Things don't necessarily work all that
well,
but there are great things to read.
I mean,
radio don't turn you inside out,
you know,
read nature.
There's lots of great thinkers there and
you know,
you have to read them intelligently.
People squawk about nature because he
was slightly misogynistic,
but I mean,
God,
he was sick.
He could hardly even see.
You can only write like one sentence at
a time.
He lived alone.
He didn't get along with women.
They were always rejecting them,
you know,
not the same thing to do with the women.
And he didn't know if anyone ever was
ever going to read what he wrote.
He sold like 500 copies of beyond good
and evil.
It's like,
so now when they did go to Noida,
didn't wrote something snippy.
It's like Jesus gave the guy a break,
you know?
And so when you read Freud as well,
you know,
this stuff's dated so you have to adjust
your reading for the context.
But when someone comes across a slate of
mysogeny mystic statement and says,
Oh,
well I'm not reading this person,
all they're saying is they're too stupid
to separate the wheat from the chaff or
too lazy.
It's like,
well,
I don't have to read nature.
Well that's a relief,
that's for sure.
Really.
So I was thinking more about parents who
are trying to make a decision to send
their kids to university.
It's like
so much of it is corrupt social work and
anthropology,
social psychology,
education,
English literature.
A huge chunk of the humanities,
which is absolute catastrophe.
The humanities school universities are
done because they're the sole of the
universities technical training.
There's.
You can be trained technically in all
sorts of other ways.
Incorporations are starting to figure
this out fast.
So we lose the humanities.
The universities are gone and we're
losing them fast because all they do is
teach you identity politics.
Jesus,
you can learn the rules that came in one
day,
right?
Divide the world into oppressed and
oppressor.
That's easy,
man.
That's a snap.
Assume the old presses are the bad
people in the oppressed or the good
people that's easy.
Make noise about it and feel good.
That's basically that.
And you know,
don't pay any attention to your role.
So $2,000
while in the university is a for a big
shakeup because they don't know what's
going to hit them with,
with youtube and online lectures.
They've got no idea what's coming down
the pipes,
so because it,
because online lectures are powerful
beyond belief and someone who's going to
sort out the accreditation for all in
the next four or five years,
a couple universities off at their
knees,
so certainly going to come within the
next 10 years.
My question
for is as a training therapist for her,
how do you think that that might bags?
That's the process of therapy.
Well,
it puts you in there with all sorts of a
priori axioms.
Know one of the things I really liked
Carl Rogers and one of the things Rogers
does is listen to what you do as a
therapist.
The better you aren't listening to
pastor,
your clients will get better and you
have to listen without prejudice and I
don't mean that in the technical sense.
It's like,
okay,
so I'm listening to you.
It's like I don't know what you're going
to say and I don't know if you're right
and I'm not going to tell you what to do
because I don't know what you should do.
And that's something about being a
therapist is like you do not want to
tell people what to do because that's
their life that you might screw it up.
So what do you want to do is listen to
them very,
very carefully and let them unwind their
story.
And most of them they'll take care of
themselves,
you know,
because no one's listened to them so
they don't even know what they think
their head is full of jumbled mess of
thoughts and experiences.
It's like it's like a tangling of knots
and maybe the person needs to talk for
like three years to sort it all out.
And what you should do is listen to them
from a different culture,
whatever,
like there's going to be friction
because of that,
because you'll come out at least to some
degree with different assumptions.
But
read the damn therapists.
Those people were smart.
They tell you things about.
Each of them gives you a different
toolbox.
They're not scientific theories.
Exactly,
but as a clinician,
you're not a scientist.
You're a.
you're an engineer of the soul.
That's a better way of thinking about it
because it's an applied.
It's like engineering,
it's an applied science,
so makes it not a science.
Exactly.
You can use scientific knowledge,
but you're still aiming at the good,
right?
That's what you're doing as a therapist
with the other person.
You say,
look,
you already know that things aren't as
good for you as they need to be.
We're going to work on that and you're
here to make things better and I'm here
to help you figure out how to make
things better.
Then I'll listen to you and we'll move
toward some place that's lighter and
better and and then you have tools that
you can use in that kind of analytical
listening process and the great
psychotherapists math.
Most people have their 10,000 hours,
you know,
they all come at it from slightly
different.
Temperamental perspectives like young's
work is really useful for dealing with
people who are high in openness.
So his whole philosophy is you have an
open client,
you'll works if you have a conservative
clients,
forget it.
It's,
it's a whole different thing.
What I'm hearing from you is that that
postmodern stance is helpful for the
therapy from off,
from what you're saying is that listen
and that you're,
that you're not giving an absolute truth
to these,
to these clients.
Yeah,
but the problem is the postmodern thing
works out pretty well,
but they keep asking it in Marxism.
It's like,
oh yeah,
but their primary identity is,
is is like sex or gender or ethnicity or
race.
It's like,
no,
sorry,
we're not going there,
so it's not exactly postmodernism
because the postmodernists are
misinformed about the nature of
scientific theories.
I think they don't really see them as
tools,
but I see the best tools and so you can
have a diverse range of tools and they
don't eat.
Each one doesn't have to claim a pistol
biological or ontological priority,
but that means that you have to view
those sorts of theories as tools that
makes you a pragmatist post modernists.
All right,
and speaking of patients.
Okay,
in an hour or so,
a few things I want to wrap up now just
to that point.
I said this earlier today and first of
all,
one of the reasons I really wanted to
have Dr Peterson comment,
and first of all,
Cirina,
thank you very much for arranging that.
Uh,
she did.
She said that she wants to go to have
you come in and say,
yeah,
sure.
And she did it until he really
appreciate a serene.
It'd be,
especially Dr Peterson,
you know,
I would have preferred to have broadcast
as widely known what I want all the
Peterson haters to come in.
I want you to have a chance to be able
to actually face to face,
confront what you're afraid of.
Don't be ignorant,
don't just impose your own beliefs and
your biases and everything onto what you
were saying,
but actually hear process and come to a
reality and fact based conclusion about
the things that you're trying to promote
because in today's society,
truly everything you've been talking
about,
I don't think it's like verbally.
I think that we are going down a
dangerous path.
We're seeing the consequences of it.
And I've been in all my students know
this.
I have been promoting this in therapy.
Uh,
anything like glasses and my family,
this idea that you need to be able to
expose yourself to things that make you
uncomfortable,
that you're not aware of.
And that's,
yeah,
that's kind of a ground rule of good.
It might be
psychotherapy speaking,
I'm being honest,
honest about yourself,
honestly.
What your biases,
your,
your ignorance and your fears,
your flaws.
You can't grow without that.
So this to me was a metaphorical,
a metaphoric of the,
I guess,
manifestation of that desire.
I wanted to bring you here and I really
do appreciate you taking the time.
I know you've got many speaking
engagements.
I do appreciate that and I'm glad that
some people have very pointed questions
that you're able to address.
What are they going to do with a video?
What's the for that?
Um,
uh,
being very low in conscientiousness.
I haven't thought that far ahead.
Going dropbox and you look.
Well,
I'll definitely give you the uh,
lots of people will watch it.
So great.
It doesn't matter that that's the thing
that's cool about youtube.
We will have you have a stadium stadium
now.
Every time I talk,
which is weird,
man,
it's
going to be uploading it and send it to
you and we'll make the arrangements.
So thank you very much again for coming
and thank you everybody for [inaudible].
Thank you.